did you go to Nimoy's funeral
uh I did you did he was he was uh one of
the the sweetest and most thought he was
just the dream version of of uh of a
gentleman when you say that in other
words when you directed him he was fun
he was he couldn't say this there was a
day when we were shooting
on on the first Star Trek movie that we
did and
he was going down this very narrow
Corridor of this uh this Spaceship set
and he fell
and he hit his nose and he broke his
nose oh dear and he had a gash on his
nose and I thought holy crap this is a
you know a disaster a disaster and he's
like you know 70s I just felt horrible
and uh he's in his 70s at that point
yeah yeah I don't want to kill myself
what are you doing to these people
that's the thing right and Leonard after
about you know he's kind of you know
shaken up and everything about
um uh about 20 minutes later he's like
let's keep going and we kept shooting
and they put makeup over and we shot
like four more hours with this guy he
was just a rockstar well he's a Vulcan
they don't have any emotions
that's right why is there uh such
secrecy about the fact that you broke
your back during the filming of Star
Wars you literally broke your back
there's no secret I talked about it on
uh on The Daily Show there's no secrecy
what happened was uh that when this
hydraulic door came down yeah and it
pushed down the person who happened to
be right there under it who happened to
be Harrison Ford right so he got hurt
not the ideal scenario his his uh his
leg broke Wow and his ankle went went
sideways like 90 degrees really pretty
scary yeah and so I'm there with with
one of my uh Idols uh who's now down on
the ground not an ideal scenario for him
so I go and try and lift up this door as
any of us would
a kind of like Hulk I'm gonna lift the
car up off the person I love energy and
you go over to lifted what I discover uh
in doing that are two things one is a
hydraulic door cannot be lifted yeah
unless it wants to be lifted and
secondly uh bones uh brick so I feel
this pop in my lower back and I think
[ __ ] I think what is that is it a muscle
whatever and I'm just all I'm trying to
do is is help my friend and seconds
later the door is opened up by a
gentleman who has a giant button
and uh all day my back is hurting and of
course all I care about is the fact that
Harrison has uh has broken his language
and God knows what else you just don't
know at that moment right you'd have no
idea what's going on and uh anyway that
night Hospital uh thank God he's gonna
be okay and and he ends up coming back
three months later to shoot basically
his whole scene his whole uh role in the
film and he's fine but about a week
later I had to wait three months for him
to shoot his role uh yeah doesn't that
how does that work I mean rearrange a
schedule we shot everything we could up
front and then Harrison went off to
recover and did so amazingly and came
back just you know on fire right but a
week after I go to the doctor and get a
scan and the doctor is explaining to me
this London Doctor is explaining how I
probably have this strain he's looking
at my scan and I see his face go white
and he goes oh my God your back is
broken oh my God you fractured your L4
and he shows me this thing and so I have
to wear this brace and you're walking
around I'm walking around like an idiot
so for two months I'm wearing this brace
under my a shirt and I didn't tell
anyone on the on the crew because I just
I didn't want anyone to be like
kick gloves